[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 Ecuador lanzó su
ministerio de la mujer y Derechos
Humanos y un registro único de violencia
se espera que esta herramienta reúna la
información de Nueva instituciones del
estado para atender los casos de
violencia de manera coordinada y así
poder prevenir los feminicidios Solo
este año van al menos 272 de estos
crímenes en el país el presidente de
Ecuador Guillermo lasso firmó el decreto
durante la creación de la cartera en el
lanzamiento del Roof que fue elaborado
con el programa de las Naciones Unidas
para el desarrollo y la iniciativa
Spotlight de la Unión Europea
con el registro tendremos un historial
de las víctimas sus datos nivel de
Educación si tiene empleo Si recibe el
bono de solidaridad
si ha puesto denuncias en fiscalía si
tiene juicios de alimentos Quién es su
pareja qué hace
toda esta información
nos permitirá evaluar el nivel del
riesgo para actuar con rapidez vamos a
tener una conversación sobre esta
noticia y para ello la invitada es decir
eviteri ella es abogada politóloga y
experta en temas de igualdad de género y
violencia contra la mujer además de
empoderamiento femenino también
pertenece a la red de politólogas es
decir gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros en ellas hoy
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación un
gusto participar con ustedes Bueno pues
estamos con esta noticia que puede ser
una una gran noticia para las mujeres
que durante años han pedido esta
herramienta y además la creación del
Ministerio de la mujer Usted cree que
esta es la respuesta a las protestas
masivas de septiembre por el feminicidio
de la abogada María Belén Bernal en la
escuela superior de la policía porque
cree que este caso hizo la diferencia
Por supuesto que el caso hizo la
diferencia pero no es el único caso hay
varios casos y todos tienen que tomarse
con la misma responsabilidad y como
estado por supuesto tenemos que seguir
trabajando para que no exista ningún
femicidio Más sin embargo el rubro no
nace como respuesta a eso sino que
realmente tenía ya unos antecedentes
anteriores Entonces en ese Marco es
importante entender el concepto y el
origen de esta herramienta Esta es una
herramienta que extrae información de
manera georeferencial referente a
eventos de violencia contra las mujeres
en todas sus diversidades y esta
herramienta se origina en el marco de
una ley la Ley Orgánica integral para
prevenir y erradicar la violencia contra
las mujeres que es de mayo de 2018 y
también en el marco del Sistema Nacional
integral para prevenir y erradicar la
violencia contra las mujeres una de las
principales disposiciones de la ley que
menciono tenía como objetivo que se dé
vida a este registro único de violencia
y este pasado martes 29 de noviembre el
presidente presentó el ruc y también en
este mismo espacio pues anunció la
creación del nuevo Ministerio de la
mujer y Derechos Humanos entonces creo
que son dos hitos importantes no solo a
nivel nacional sino a nivel incluso
regional porque Ecuador puede pasar a
ser un ejemplo de cómo con datos podemos
crear mejores políticas públicas
hablemos de esos datos Porque si viene
la idea digamos está muy bien planteada
de una coordinación que nos permita
saber cuáles mujeres están en situación
de vulnerabilidad si están recibiendo
apoyos económicos si han tenido
antecedentes de violencia por ejemplo de
sus parejas en todo esto para que pueda
hacerse una realidad necesita no
solamente de un presupuesto sino también
de un enfoque de género por parte de las
personas que lo van a ejecutar está
Ecuador preparado para esto porque
herramientas de este tipo existen en
otras en otras partes de la región y en
otras partes del mundo y a veces no son
exitosas Simplemente porque cuando
llevan a la práctica pues no existe la
formación en género
Claro Mira desde ese ámbito yo te podría
contar la experiencia desde el
Ministerio de salud pública
esta herramienta necesita de un trabajo
con tecnologías por ejemplo pero también
con un enfoque de género Entonces desde
el Ministerio de salud pública la
instancia de tics con derechos humanos
Acompaña a la herramienta Es decir desde
el Ministerio de salud la dirección
Nacional de Derechos Humanos género e
inclusión a quien dirección que lidero
ha hecho el trabajo de organizar
internamente a todos los involucrados en
este proceso de articulación del ruc con
los técnicos internos del nivel nacional
para su implementación es decir hay un
trabajo conjunto porque no podríamos
hacerlo únicamente desde género porque
nos pasaría factura es decir No
tendríamos de este componente
tecnológico y también el área
tecnológica tal vez no podría abordar el
enfoque de género que requiere si no
tuviese este acompañamiento de los
Derechos Humanos entonces creo que esa
sinergia entre entre los diferentes
componentes de las instituciones ayuda a
que esta herramienta pueda caminar
porque no ha sido un trabajo sencillo ha
sido un trabajo complicado porque cada
ministerio tiene sus datos Y ha habido
que homologar estas variables y cabe
mencionar que estamos apenas en una fase
inicial una fase uno punto cero que irá
paulatinamente involucrando a las demás
instituciones como bien se mencionaba
inicialmente están nueve estas son el
consejo de la judicatura la fiscalía
general del estado el Ministerio de
Educación el Ministerio de inclusión
económica y social el Ministerio del
interior el Ministerio de salud pública
la Policía Nacional el sistema integrado
de seguridad eco nueve uno uno y por
supuesto el Ministerio de la mujer y de
Derechos Humanos
desde el 2014 se tipificó en el país el
delito del feminicidio dentro del Código
Penal desde entonces son más de 1.319
mujeres en registro fallecidas por
violencia de género para llegar hasta la
creación de esta herramienta que
pretende prevenir las violencias Ustedes
han hecho un trabajo previo en el que
por ejemplo hayan podido identificar a
causas estructurales del feminicidio en
el caso específico del Ecuador
Claro que sí se han identificado causas
estructurales que es exactamente en lo
que se está priorizando también el
trabajo a nivel país por ejemplo desde
el Ministerio de salud pública en
nuestro trabajo está orientado a la
atención de las víctimas pero también
podemos Buscar herramientas para poder
como esta apoyando al desarrollo del ruc
También estamos trabajando en la
prevención Porque si solamente
trabajamos en atención es llegar tarde
es llegar tarde porque quiere decir que
ya estamos atendiendo casos y que
eventualmente esos casos también pueden
ser femicidios y lo que queremos es como
país que esa cifra vaya decreciendo
actualmente las cifras en Ecuador son
dolorosas cada 28 horas tenemos una
muerte de mujer por causa de género es
decir un femicidio y realmente esto Pues
nos da la Pauta de que hace falta mucha
reflexión hace falta mucho trabajo y por
eso también queremos orientar acciones
hacia la prevención y no solamente a la
atención para
terminar en en Casos tan dolorosos como
el de María Belén Bernal y que se
refleja en la cifra que mencionábamos al
principio del programa que son ya casi
300 casos de feminicidios y no se ha
terminado todavía el año nos queda un
mes largo para todavía hacer algunos de
estos registros ahora Ustedes han
encontrado que hay por ejemplo desafíos
en el tema judicial porque muchas veces
los feminicidios pues está tipificados
en el código penal no son debidamente
registrados por las autoridades Entonces
tenemos todavía casos que se mencionan
como homicidio el homicidio de una mujer
por o otro tipo de crímenes pero el
feminicidio sigue quedando bastante en
la sombra Usted cree que este este
término está al menos encaminado a estar
más dentro de la comprensión de la
ciudadanía y sobre todo de las
autoridades encargadas Pues de ponerlo
en tela de juicio
yo creo que realmente se ha avanzado
desde la tipificación Por supuesto que
esto es insuficiente si al final la
normativa termina por no aplicarse de
manera correcta sin embargo Ecuador el
ser pionero en haber tipificado este
delito hace que el tema ya esté en la
agenda pública y En este gobierno se ha
dicho que es una prioridad el tema de la
atención a Víctimas de de violencia de
género y creo que en ese sentido el
compromiso fuerte va a ser que realmente
al implementar esta herramienta tengamos
mejores políticas públicas y que con
esta Data como estado podamos realmente
realizar planes programas proyectos
investigaciones que realmente busquen
prevenir y erradicar la violencia ya no
solamente desde desde la problemática
sino desde antes ya habiendo
identificado elementos Como por ejemplo
la sociedad machista que a partir de eso
podamos realmente utilizar esta
herramienta como un mejor sustento para
generar políticas públicas que realmente
le ayuden a la población y que también
realmente nos den Data al estado como
tal para poder responder oportunamente
en fases distintas es decir por ejemplo
en el sistema de Salud si yo tengo un
caso de violencia psicológica y mediante
el rubro identificar que se trata de una
niña que no o por ejemplo un adolescente
que no está asistiendo a la escuela que
tiene
familiar por ejemplo un padrastro ya
tengo algunos elementos que me van a ir
generando ciertas alertas de en base a
otros casos y a raíz de eso Por ejemplo
en una intervención oportuna en
violencia psicológica de alguna víctima
podríamos luego evitar un gasto de
violencia física y etcétera pues Mire yo
creo que la noticia es saludada por los
movimientos de mujeres sobre todo con el
Ministerio de la mujer que sería el
referente y bueno que veremos cómo
funciona de aquí en adelante ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo pero también queda
para la reflexión de este programa Todo
lo que tiene que aprender todavía
Ecuador sobre este tema para poder
llevar a cabo estos objetivos y cierro
simplemente con las declaraciones del
presidente que hablaba de eliminar un
problema que no distingue de clases
sociales de religión ni de color de piel
y sin embargo deciré lo que nos ha
mostrado la historia es que eso no es
tan así y que sí hay unas
características de vulnerabilidad que
deben ser atacadas para proteger a las
mujeres dicho esto el agradecimiento
para usted y para nuestros televidentes
por ahondar en un tema que puede ser muy
beneficioso para las latinoamericanas
Muchas gracias saludos y a nuestros
televidentes que sigan con nosotros en
France 24 y nos vemos Próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]